that's not the plan
Jaden what would be for you his biggest
strength as a father and something you'd
like to see him improve on yeah
okay great question
um
strength is that
I think that everyone thinks that he's
not around but he is around we don't we
live in the same general area he's
around multiple times a week obviously
now this is one mile for me he's
obviously on house arrest now but you
know what I'm saying we've already made
the effort to do that I don't he's not
an absent dad so that's not his weakness
what he could improve on would maybe be
like disciplining I don't think that I
think that I'm more the like I have to
you got to lay the hair yeah yeah and he
wants to come around yeah like he's like
I got presents and I have we
can we can get Wingstops 70 Wings let's
get 70 wings like you want to jump off
the roof let's jump off the route like
he's that but I think that as far as
disciplining he could help me a little
more because I think that our son is
getting to the age where it's kind of
like how I don't have to listen to Mom
he's six oh yeah he's getting there he's
like he's kind of like I don't have to
listen to him he's been a kid though
it's not like he's yeah but like I can't
even give him a curse like it's not like
he's doing belligerent things yeah it's
more like he's he was at least he's
finding out his controls you feel me
it's like when you go when you with your
mom all day
uh she's gonna be one in August so it's
kind of like I'm dealing with her I
don't he's like I'm gonna jump off the
bed
up the bed I'm dealing
I'm a dirty diaper like great and then
he'll jump off the bed but also do three
back flips and then it's like I didn't
tell you to do that you know what I mean
like I didn't tell you to do that so why
are we doing nothing out of the ordinary
he's being sick but I need him to be
like I need you to I need you to listen
to Mom unplug the PlayStation yes yes
because sometimes he'll I'll be like
clean your room take a shower then you
can play Playstation yeah he'll empty
the whole Toy Box like
I'm not cleaning [__] I'm not taking a
shower none of that I'm just play
Playstation why would you do that it's
hard for me to like be mean to him
that's what I mean like sometimes she'll
be doing overboard though it's like
she'd be just tripping off
overboard it's having it's having like
he like can I get a snack no you can't
get no [__] snacks shut the [__] down
no because he's like damn
let him have three snacks before dinner
why are you having three Sexes
you're not gonna eat dinner exactly and
then you're gonna stay up all night
again um next in black and Asian so this
is the thing about a Mexican woman if
you don't eat dinner yeah
oh you ate something before you came
home didn't you because you ain't
[__] up that food like you should be
and it's like damn it's not that serious
yeah it is though because then when
they're when you're knocked out Drool on
the pillow at 12 a.m and they're like I
want a sandwich I want something oh hell
no we already made dinner and I'd be
like damn why you like this because you
be sleep that's fine